lo que vamos a hacer en este vídeo es
pensar en la toma de decisiones óptimas
por parte de agentes racionales es
pensar cómo una persona lógica con gran
capacidad de razonamiento toma
decisiones óptimas toma las mejores
decisiones para sí misma bueno estas
personas analizarían los costos y
beneficios de una decisión e intentarían
realizar las acciones que maximicen la
diferencia entre costo y beneficio de
modo que ellos quieren maximizar los
beneficios beneficios menos costos y
esta es una idea importante porque
pienso que a todos nosotros nos gustaría
ser agentes racionales agentes lógicos
que toman decisiones óptimas ahora
pensando en beneficios y costos los
beneficios probablemente los quieras
cuantificar de alguna manera tal vez en
pesos
digamos cuál es el beneficio de ir al
cine o tomar un helado y el costo
tendremos que asociarlo con el precio el
costo de ir al cine probablemente es de
100 pesos a ese tipo de cosas se les
conoce como costos
explícitos cuando existe un precio
explícito asociado pero también hay algo
conocido como costos implícitos y la
mejor manera de definir el costo
implícito es como un costo de
oportunidad el costo de oportunidad en
términos económicos se define como el
costo de la siguiente mejor alternativa
de modo que si voy a ver una película
podría haber un costo explicito de pagar
la película pero luego está el costo
implícito tal vez y voy a ver una
película ese tiempo lo podría haber
usado para otra cosa tal vez podría
haber ganado dinero de alguna manera por
lo que un actor nacional consideraría
ambas opciones las compararía con el
beneficio de ir al cine y si eso es lo
que maximiza la diferencia entre
beneficios y costos entonces podría
decidir hacer eso ahora para hacer esto
un poco más tangible veamos el ejemplo
exacto así que justo aquí nos dicen
supongamos que tienes la opción de ir al
cine durante tres horas en lugar de
trabajar por tres horas los boletos de
cine cuestan 100 pesos
si trabajas puedes ganar 300 pesos por
ahora cortando el pasto 120 pesos la
hora por trabajar en una heladería o 100
pesos la hora por arreglar el jardín de
tu tía cuál es el costo de oportunidad
de ir a ver una película durante 3 horas
y cuál es el costo total así que a pausa
en el vídeo y traten de resolverlo bien
solo tenemos que volver a la definición
el costo de oportunidad es el costo de
la siguiente mejor alternativa entonces
cuál es la siguiente mejor alternativa
después de ir al cine bueno puedo ganar
la mayor cantidad de dinero si cortó el
pasto y así me costo de oportunidad será
de 300 pesos por hora y si voy a ver una
película serían 3 horas en las que no
podría cortar el pasto por lo que mi
costo de oportunidad escribiré se o el
costo de oportunidad será de 300 pesos
por hora por 3 horas 300 por 3 es igual
a 900 pesos de costo de oportunidad y
algunos de ustedes podrían decir bueno
qué hay de los 120 pesos por hora por
trabajar en una heladería o de los 100
pesos por
por arreglar el jardín de tu tía bueno
esas no eran la siguiente mejor
alternativa la siguiente mejor
alternativa era cortar el pasto algunas
personas podrían estar confundidas y
decir está bien voy a sumar todas estas
cosas por ahora y multiplicar las por 3
pero no podrás hacer estas tres cosas al
mismo tiempo vas a tener que elegir una
de ellas y suponemos que probablemente
no haya costos adicionales tal vez te
canses más por cortar el pasto que por
trabajar en una heladería pero estamos
tratando de simplificar las cosas así
que no nos compliquemos demasiado ahora
entonces en un nivel muy alto o en un
nivel alto la siguiente mejor
alternativa es ganar 300 pesos por hora
por cortar el pasto de modo que ese
sería el costo de oportunidad ahora cuál
sería el costo total
bueno el costo total sería la suma de
los costos implícitos de los cuales el
costo de oportunidad es un ejemplo más
el costo explícito ya hablamos de los
costos implícitos 900 pesos es el costo
de oportunidad de no cortar el pasto
y luego a eso le sumamos el costo
explícito del precio del boleto del cine
por 100 pesos puedes ver una película
durante tres horas así que hay un costo
explícito de 100 pesos por lo que el
costo de ir a la película es de 1000
pesos entonces de qué manera los agentes
racionales usarían esta información para
tomar una decisión óptima bueno ellos
quisieran comparar eso con el beneficio
de ir al cine y si pudieran cuantificar
ese beneficio de alguna manera y decir
oh sí el beneficio para mí de ir al cine
es de dos mil pesos y la diferencia
entre dos mil pesos y mil pesos es la
mejor que puedo obtener de todas mis
opciones entre mis beneficios y mis
costos bueno entonces voy a ir al cine
lo dejaremos ahí y en futuros vídeos
profundizaremos un poco más en esto
hasta el próximo vídeo